so we're given this function X minus 4
over x squared minus X minus 12 and we
want to find the limit as X approaches 4
using this table here now the thing is
when you do the table method I'm going
to show you on the graphing calculator
how to do it but just to show you here
on paper what you want to do is you're
approaching this x value of 4 and you're
trying to see you know what it gets
closer and closer to as you approach 4
from below and from above meaning a
little bit lower than 4 and a little bit
higher than 4 now if you try to put 4 in
directly for ax here in this particular
problem what you're gonna get is 0
divided by 0 which is called
indeterminate mean we can't determine
what the limit is so when you put this
in on your calculator you're gonna get
like an error it's gonna say it like you
know undefined right well the numbers
that we want to pick here on either side
we're gonna want to pick a number that's
slightly smaller here by let's say like
a thousandth so this would be like 3 9 9
9 and then this one here is gonna be
slightly more like four point zero zero
one so we're going larger by a thousand
and then smaller by a thousandth and
larger by a hundredth smaller by a
hundredth and then larger by a tenth
smaller by a tenth but as far as the
graphing calculator is concerned what
you want to do is you want to go over
here let me zoom in what we want to do
is we want to go to y equals here
okay so y equals and we're gonna put in
our function so what do we have here
we've got X minus 4 and then you want to
put that in parentheses so it takes it
as a group
divided by and then the denominator is X
minus 12 okay so now what we're gonna do
is we're going to go before we go to our
table you want to go to where it says
table set here right above window so
press 2nd table set and what you want to
make sure is you want to make sure that
you're set for not for auto which is
oftentimes is on for the independent
variable you want to make sure that it's
on ask okay so we're gonna make sure
it's selected for asked and we're going
to go now to second table which is right
above graph here and we're gonna put in
these values here that we were talking
about earlier so we want to go ahead and
put some there a little bit below 4 and
a little bit there above 4 so I'm going
to go and put 3.9
okaythat's and i'm gonna do three point
nine nine three point nine nine nine so
you can see i'm almost to four if we put
foreign notice how it gives us an error
and then if we put in slightly larger
than four by a thousand four point zero
zero one slightly larger by a hundred
that's four point zero one and then
slightly larger by a tenth four point
one what you want to do here is you want
to again make sure that when you're
approaching for from below meaning lower
and from above higher that they're
approaching the same number and you can
see it's getting closer and closer to
like point one four to eight right okay
and so that's going to be your limit
point one four three I'm just going
around approximately if you do this
using other techniques which I'm going
to link to a video that talks about
using other different techniques for
finding limits in precalculus you can
figure out that this is exactly a limit
of 1/7 okay but I'll show you I'll see
you over in that other video and we'll
talk more about limits there